et on prend la direction de kiev où nous
attend le correspondant france 24
gulliver craag bonjour gulliver on
imagine que ces révélations à manouche
commence à faire beaucoup de bruit à
travers le pays caisson est les
dernières informations dont vous
disposez
alors ce sont des images qui confirme un
peu ce que vadim boychenko le maire de
marioupol en exil en exil de la ville
disait déjà depuis un certain temps sur
le nombre de morts dans la ville et le
fait que les russes les emmener dans des
fosses communes il a aussi accusé la
russie d'utiliser des crématoriums
mobile pour brûler les corps des civils
mais de cela on n'a pas la confirmation
mais les images satellites s'accorde
avec ce que dit mme aubry jean paul
disait en tout cas pour ce qui est des
fosses communes de sont fausses ou les
autorités ukrainiennes estiment qu'il
peut y avoir jusqu'à 9000 corps on ne
sait pas vadim bochenko faisait la
comparaison on l'a entendu je pense avec
bcia ou des civils ont été fusillés pour
le cas de marioupol on ne sait pas et on
pourra pas savoir je pense avant
longtemps si ces personnes ont été
fusillées comme ç'avait été le cas pour
de nombreux habitants de boudhha juste
en dehors de kef ou bien si ce sont des
personnes qui sont tout simplement un
mort dans les combats dans le
bombardement de la ville il faut bien
croire que quand une ville d'un demi
million d'habitants est pilonnée par
l'artillerie et par des bombardements
aériens pendant plusieurs semaines avec
plus de 95% de ses bâtiments sévèrement
endommagés cela fait beaucoup de dégâts
humains aussi et il est pratiquement
certain qu'il y a beaucoup de civils à
marioupol qui sont morts tout simplement
à cause des bombardements ce qui est une
constitue un crime de guerre aussi très
probablement puisque il est un crime de
guerre de cibler les zones civiles
compte il n'y a pas de cible militaire
visible en proximité mais ce n'est pas
exactement la même chose que de
massacrer les personnes comme ils l'ont
fait à butch à un coup de pistolet
un gulliver bonjour alors qu'il y à ces
nouveaux soupçons de massacres
l'offensive russe elle continue dans le
donbass
les russes n'avance pas beaucoup sur le
sol pour le moment depuis les débuts de
cette nouvelle offensive pour essayer de
prendre le reste d'une basse pour le
moment ils ont pris qu'une seule ville
crémines à ces noms loi de severodonetsk
du robinet hier ils disaient qu'ils
avaient pris le contrôle de rubigen est
aussi mais les ukrainiens ne l'admettent
pas les experts américains estiment que
c'est faux que les russes n'ont pas pris
rugby je n'ai donc pas de gain
territoriale vraiment sur le front de
l'est pour le moment mais les experts
américains pensent aussi que la russie
n'a pas encore déployé toute la force de
frappe qu'elle sera capable de déployer
dans ces régions merci gulliver vous
étiez en direct de kiev
heyer